cette scène filmée il ya trois ans et
dévoilé peu de temps après par le
journal le monde a provoqué un scandale
politique la sphère benalla place de la
contrescarpe à paris ce collaborateur de
l'elysée inconnu du grand public frappe
violemment des manifestants lors du
rassemblement du 1er mai lors de son
audition dans le cadre d'une commission
d' enquête en septembre 2018 l'intéressé
s'est défendu selon lui son geste était
nécessaire c'était un réflexe citoyen et
non pas un tabassage mais il a tout de
même admis quelques thors j'ai commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs
des erreurs que je hais reconnu
volontiers
auprès de mes proches
près de mon entourage et que je
reconnais publiquement devant vous et je
les fais également devant la justice
l'ex collaborateur de l'elysée est
également poursuivi dans deux autres
affaires
l'utilisation de passeports
diplomatiques utilisés en afrique en
israël après son limogeage de l'elysée
est un sel fille dans un restaurant en
2017 où l'on aperçoit benalla braqué une
arme à feu en direction d'une serveuse
lors du rapport de la commission
denquête des dysfonctionnements ont été
relevés concernant le recrutement
d'alexandre benalla un manque de suivi
semble-t-il du collaborateur
tu recrutement puisque le recrutement
n'a pas été fait avec un contrôle
quelconque de ses antécédents qui aurait
peut-être permis de ne pas le recruter
jusqu'à son départ de l'elysée où on
voit qu'il n'ya aucune suite à son
départ pour récupérer les instruments de
son travail ce qui se fait pour
n'importe quel salarié tout au long du
procès qui s'est tenu en septembre
dernier alexandre benalla a défendu son
innocence sur presque tous les faits qui
lui sont reprochés à ses côtés vincent
crasse ex agent de sécurité du parti en
marche et deux commissaires de la
préfecture de paris ont également été
poursuivis l'un pour des violences
commises lors de ce 1er mai et les deux
autres pour avoir transmis des images de
vidéosurveillance alexandre benalla ce
vendredi le tribunal correctionnel de
paris doit rendre son jugement l'ancien
chargé de mission à l'elysée risque
jusqu'à 18 mois de prison avec sursis 1
500 euros d'amendé cinq ans
d'interdiction de toute fonction
publique et dix ans d'interdiction de
port d'armes